three two one
hey what's up welcome back to winners on
a wednesday where every single wednesday
i interview one of my success students
who is smashing it in property
and i'm really really really excited to
introduce you today to george
george has got his own hotel that he
controls which is making him 15
000 profit a month he's also got
multiple other property investment deals
so i can't wait to interview him if you
enjoy my youtube channel please give me
a massive favor
smash like also don't forget to
subscribe and turn on the notification
bell
george thank you so much for traveling
down to my house thank you man i
appreciate them here so you're in sweden
yeah baby so you're from sweden tell me
who is george
how did you get started give me a little
bit of background george is from
bulgaria from this is my background
bulgaria and uh me my wife
long time ago maybe 25 years ago we met
with her so we started from bulgaria to
looking for
a looking for a place to live somewhere
because our country was like
economically like like not so so good
you know
yeah so we need to find some place some
country to live in
so we were traveling traveling traveling
and finally we just
landed to sweden 2007 i think 87 i was
30 years old then
and uh now 15 years i'm living there
with her we have built our
swedish business there i'm electrician
and that's my
electrician electrical business uh in
sweden
is going great you know my life is
beautiful there it's like i have
everything i want everything house a
nice car i
like i like sport cars
like okay like you're your friend also
dude
yeah yeah and my brother just bought a
porsche uh you have to
i have makan for shimakang so that's my
favorite car
yeah and then i that's me no i'm living
in 15 years in sweden
that's my new country that's my new life
i'm happy there you know
and uh i'm working there still working
and i decided some
southerners my wife we have to do
something about this this uh
future what i mean because my work in
sweden is very depend of
me physically so if i cannot work my
work we're
like dumb we cannot continue with our
life
so we were starting to think about what
shall we find
uh to to bring us pacific income you
know because you can stay home
and go meet people and earn money this
way not just
working physically starting to google
she was googling googling my wife she
found properties
okay we tried properly we found a we
found
a course in in sweden like property
course we went there
like it was like a one month course then
we
we attend to their academy actually
my babysitting like your academy but in
sweden i
i felt myself like in their course of
course i felt
like a in slowly process it was very
slowly course and
everything was happening just slowly
slowly i i needed speed
and then i just said i must google it
and find something in england
i was typing in youtube the property
investments in uk and you came up first
as a result so i click on
your youtube video start watching you
start following you
and then i decided to attend to your
crash courses
two times i went to crash courses then
one year ago
the last course i went to was this deal
fighting through a ganza so hold on
let me just stop you right there longest
long story you know
no but it's very interesting but you
just said you were you went on a course
in sweden it was a bit slow and a bit
yes you weren't joking too well so you
watched my youtube videos and then you
came to my crash course but weren't you
living in sweden
yes absolutely so you jumped on a plane
yeah because of you but the thing is
that that's massive
this much you know you had a successful
business in electrics yes you're making
some money
you want to make some passive income
exactly most people won't even take
a long car drive i know that yes right
but but it's in part of this interview i
think it's important to break down
yes your mentality of how you've become
successful yeah a lot of people have
said
oh my course isn't amazing i'm not
really getting with it
but this course looks good but it's in
england and i live in sweden so i can't
go but you didn't you said it's in
england
but i'm going to jump on a plane of
course you know talk me through
did that not take did that not take a
lot of thinking through or a lot of
i i thought i think about this kind of
stuff five seconds
you know i mean not five hours fast i
was just when i find your
your education said to my wife i'm there
i go there doesn't yeah i decided
straight away you know straight away so
it took me five seconds to decide so
when you got to the crash course yeah
and as well like
we have a lot of people flying overseas
exactly we stand we probably stood
did i get you to stand up yes because
you asked always in the beginning you
asked
are you guys from where are you guys
from you know what is that sweden can
you please
stand up sweden student guy and i was up
in uh just from sweden so i
was always standing up i'll actually
shout out the european countries and
people standing up
exactly so it's not it's not rare that
people fly in
a lot of people do yes but people that
are prepared to do that it just shows me
when you stood up at the time remember
thinking this guy is unstoppable
yes no i'm not absolutely right but then
you came back to a crash course
and one more time three times three
times so what was it about the crash
course that was so
compelling first when i came in the
crash course and i
i just feel the energy you know it was
something i never seen in my life
because i've been to many courses you
know different courses
but this you did something with your
course i mean with your we have you have
made something with your program with
your crush goes amazing
with people inside your europe your
stuff is not
so your your energy you know it's like
amazing that i feel just the
energy in my my body was shaking like
what is this like wow it's like
really the energy you know like like
people
talking people screaming like tony
robbie's energy you know i mean you have
you have a very very similar energy with
him like very very
positive and so that was it the energy
so it was the environment and the energy
because i felt myself in on the right
place
directly you know because i'm this kind
of guy i'm a motion guy i'm a guy who
have energy and when i i went there
that's my place
i remember you getting on the stage with
a couple of that you're with wow two
times a few times i think you even made
sure
did you make money no he meant money he
made money he made money because again
on the crash course we'll get people
doing deals yes
finding properties selling deals coming
on the stage so
okay you then did some further training
you you registered for the deal finding
extravagance exactly
and you invested in was it two three
thousand pounds three two thousand
thousand
two thousand pounds about three thousand
pounds plus more flights
yeah hotels yeah i think we spent three
days together yes three days
what happened at the deal finding
extravaganza what was it like that was
like the magic you know i learned so
much on this on this course so much you
know about
how you find deals how to solve deals
you know and
the actually i think that the most
important thing
on that kind of events it's the
networking yeah
because on that event i met my very best
two or three journal enjoyment partners
because
i work with three people who i met there
right
and we're budding now we're building pro
property portfolio with them
because of your course yeah so that you
yeah that
that cause i went there so i think the
most important is that that you meet the
right people in the right place you know
first i learned so much about different
strategies rent to rent
nobody believed me in sweden about rent
to rent rent what
did you mean no one believed you about
it they think it's illegal
i don't know why i think you met sent me
a message actually one time
you were like i'm concerned there's a
property trainer in sweden saying
it's illegal and there's a lot of stuff
going on is that what that's
what they were saying yes it's because
it's rent to rent
somehow they they knew that you cannot
just rent
from someone and rent to make money
somehow
but i learned from you that when the
landlord is signing the paper
that he is okay with that that's the
document yeah if you've got the right
agreement yes
absolutely and rent to rent is something
that to say it's illegal
as long as they're right even even even
massive companies
like exactly you do rent to rent like
some of the biggest companies use the
same philosophy so you took rent to rent
to it's extreme
which we're going to get to and freaking
hotel which is incredible
so we're the deal finding extravaganza
for three days yeah um
and one of the things that we teach on
the deal fine extravaganza is to book a
big day
exactly yeah and you you didn't book a
big day because you don't do anything by
half you booked a big week
yes so talk me through what that means
what a big day is and what you did
wow the big day the big day was when i
was when i went to from your course
crush from your the course in birmingham
defines gansa i went to
i went to sheffield yeah uh and there i
met i knew already uh elena jackson
because he she's uh
she owns a latin agency and she has many
many uh many um like vendors landlords
around her customers clients
who give her her properties their
properties
so she can rent it out so she's a
management
yeah and also um she was the lady that
helped me on my financial freedom
who yeah right so um
so and you were introduced to her
through somebody else on the academy
one more time you were introduced to
eleanor through somebody on the academy
yeah actually before i came in uh
in on this on this course uh in
birmingham
i contracted with leon the guy yeah
leonardo house because there
was them was it leon yes leon so he
he sold me he passed me a deal and uh
that deal
was with her actually with elena she was
letting this
uh apartment out for for for uh for a
landlord
and somehow he was what he was with her
some i don't know how maybe he called
her i don't know how he he
probably knew her from my video but
maybe yes yes exactly
exactly all of slime videos helps you
know yeah so uh
and then when i yes so leon he he was
the connection between me and elena
and from your course i went to sheffield
and i met her and he said i'm meeting
with some
guy and the guy came this is a hotel
look look at george we have it okay
so he just went i went with him about
the hotel
uh did the hotel have a name at the time
butler's hotel
butler's hotel yeah so there's this
hotel then and it's not a small hotel
it's a pretty decent sized hotel
like 14 apartments 14 apartments yes
okay
so you went from the deal finding
extravaganza
on the deal findings traffic cancer we
tell you book a big day
go and book loads of viewings yes yeah i
always say the person that views the
most houses wins
so you start lining up your power team
you went straight from that
and you found eleanor who's a management
comp
agency yes you found this hotel in
sheffield called butler's hotel yeah
and then what happened then uh
i just decided i take it you know
because it was
it was lighting uh 50 000 pounds
the price to pay to the guy to to like
run the business well he was selling his
uh
like a business not the hotel but the
business yeah and we we we i
decided okay i go with this you know so
i this this was a big moment to decide
to go so high because it was just the
beginning for me i was a little bit not
scared but like
hmm is that not too big for me this one
well okay how powerful the house but
this is the hotel goddammit is big
yeah i was like scared yeah but like you
know
i was like this but some same time a
little bit like
scared but i i just said no it doesn't
matter what i jump in the water
i jump in and learn how to swim in the
water you know yeah
and also the strategies though they work
with big deals or small deals
yeah so so effectively what you've done
with this hotel is a rental rent exactly
but it's just on a larger scale and you
you've basically leased
the business yes for five years yes why
would the owner
want to do that because he i think he's
kind of uh he's not so
um not so healthy somehow okay he's a
little bit sick and uh
he he he he did everything by himself
on this hotel i mean uh he was trying uh
to find people from rbooking.com
you know struggling with this one yeah
and and he didn't have a good cleaning
company
so he had a problem like a like a
headache you know like that one is too
much for me just one person you know and
that's why he decided somehow to
to to give it to someone yeah who can
just rent it out just run it
yeah he wanted like seven thousand
pounds per month uh
rent yeah so he just wanted a guaranteed
rent he didn't want to make a load
of money no he just wanted an easy life
yes when did you sign the contracts
it was same day maybe not same so so
this was like
very quick about a year and a half ago
yeah exactly okay a year so we started
we started the hotel
january last year so we're in something
so you took a hotel on
yeah just before the pandemic yeah
exactly
how is it gone oh my god that was like
what we do now it's like pandemic coming
it came and we were like
what it's like you know we were scared
something is going to be wrong
but that elena my german partners
jv she she had she had a very good
uh contract with council all right so
council
starts sending people to the hotel yeah
the whole whole pandemic period
the hotel was full hundred percent all
the time so were you making money
of course how much money we make same
like now i mean same money
we were making like 20 20 25 000
pounds almost every month profits you
know you're making 25 grams
of profit during pandemic periods
when oh my goodness the hotel
all hotels were closing was not they
have any guests we were full
because of her she found the guests you
know by campus yeah
yeah so you were making 25 grand a month
profit you were splitting that with with
your partner
yeah but we we had like maybe 10 12
expenses
right and then the rest was for us okay
okay so you're making profit of about 30
and 15 grand exactly after you paid the
landlord yeah
expenses yes okay so that one deal
financial freedom
exactly this is like amazing like i
couldn't believe it
it's true but and now what's what's
happening with it now it's running
yeah but i think now because pandemic is
finishing
and the council will stop providing us
these guests
yeah but then we will pass it to uh we
will hire
uh management company and they are from
sheffield they they will take over the
management the so you're a guy
who had a few opportunities number one
shall i jump on a plane
to go to the crash course most people
would have said no no no
but you did it yes then you had an
opportunity do you want to spend three
thousand pounds
to go on a course yeah most people would
have said no but you did it yes
then you had an opportunity to say do
you want to go
full out and book a load of viewings you
did it yeah then you have a hotel
presented itself
you said you were a bit afraid ten
percent only
i was trying to like um
but you did it yeah and now you you have
control of a hotel
absolutely it's been making you
thousands and thousands of pounds a
month
throughout the whole pandemic yes that's
unbelievable
how does it feel we were like what is
going on it's like
it's like a miracle is that something
impossible yeah becoming
possible yeah somehow you know and also
talk to me about renting it because
you've done more renter rents than the
hotel
yeah you've got multiple rent events
across sheffield yes
how do you how do you do this from
living in sweden
how have you systemized it you know it's
uh it's
uh finding the right people yeah because
first i had a
management company who i found how
do they found i think i googled it
somehow but it was not good
i mean they started to make to to manage
my properties so the hotel
first the hotel uh was uh under elena's
control
she was running it yeah but i have two
more apartments in sheffield so these
apartments
these apartments uh with this apartment
helped me a company management company
uh helped me uh in the beginning but it
was like not so well with them
okay and then i started asking on
facebook you know
uh groups like property groups somebody
knows uh
good management company in sheffield
yeah i started to get some feedbacks you
know
then i got to uh uh they i got to the
agency uh is like two girls
they're like running a uh management
property management agency
yeah call them girls i have two
apartments where i think uh george we
can help you so they started running it
you know
sure she got two other apartments in
sheffield how much are those making
one is two beds two bedrooms making
seven
eight hundred per month cash flow and
that's profit yeah profit net profit
and uh four bed apartment in daniel must
making like actually last month i did
like
two thousand pound that profits from
from the joke
yes the the four yes one of them just
one of them just one of them yes
two thousand under pandemic i had i got
like four thousand
five hundred the whole profits from the
one property uh
from from from the one apartment and a
half was for me like two thousand maybe
so together two thousand five hundred
two apartments so for the two apartments
on
average you've had some months that have
been really good yes you've had some
average monthly generally speaking
you're making about two and a half grand
yeah plus your hotel yes which is making
crazy money
that's like financial freedom financial
freedom again financial freedom again
a few times from a 3000 pound program
yeah
and of course you've had to put in a lot
of work and you've had to also
network like a maniac i've seen you
driving around the country
jumping on pines meeting people so it's
not easy massive action
yes you don't join a course here's the
thing right sometimes people think
you come on a course and i'll make you
financially free no no no no no
no no no right i will show you
i will teach you i'll put out all the
processes but then you need to then go
and actually do it and that's what you
did
the thing is many people like you said
think that
you will take their hands yeah and just
walk them through the whole process
yeah but this is wrong because you give
the people
the the i said instrument the
uh the tools yeah one toolbox yeah
instrument you know screwdriver all this
this is for you you know yeah and then
when they take the instrument
some of them cannot do something
instrument but when
when they what i mean is uh uh
wait a second um uh they think that
they think that the people think that uh
you will
take the instruments the the the tools
and do the job because of them i mean
instead of them
yeah this is the the wrong impression
maybe they have somehow i don't know how
but the thing is you're giving people
the tools
so they have to take the tools by
themselves and use the tools
yeah absolutely that's that's enough
yeah absolutely we will
we'll we'll we'll show them but we can't
do it for them but then other people
though
they think that that they're the other
extreme they're like really skeptical
and they think it doesn't work
rent-a-rents don't work um and then
they're you know
worried to take massive exactly yeah
exactly but actually the truth is it's
completely possible
you can get started with little money
with no money with lots of money yeah
but you are gonna have to put the work
in
and you're gonna have to be prepared to
do whatever it takes absolutely
but now the rewards have paid off
massively you've also got multiple other
um things going on you've got some
development projects going yes
yes talk to me a little bit about that i
started
with the guy from kent his name is ken
najoku and i'm doing doing with him a
joy venture
in uh in a project in yorkshire and it's
like
five flats house house with five flats
yeah uh already converted but they're
very really bad conditions so we're
we're we're doing renovation
all kitchens all bathrooms so we just we
just make everything new
and that's we buy and catch that house
actually right and this helps us maybe
go to my first house like
i'm buying the house not renting rent
yeah but purchasing the house
and how big is it uh 300
000 pound i think no no that's how
expensive is how big is the house how
many bedrooms or five flats
okay so it's almost like a hotel yeah a
little one
a little yeah you're controlling one
incredible
yeah yeah and he's a good guy you met
him on the um crash course still
fighting through a ganza you met on the
deal i met him there but again you're
talking about
the power of people he's very important
what would you say to somebody
that was saying maybe they're overseas
yeah they're living in sweden or
bulgaria or wherever
and they're saying i really want to
follow in your footsteps george i want
to do the same thing
but i just can't justify the time
or the expense of going back and forth
to england like how do you do that
what would you say i i would say you
have to find
some little amount of money book a hotel
you know but you know many people they
they cannot take the step you know it's
difficult for them take the step
to decide i think first the most
important thing in the mindset they have
to
have the right mindset you know the
mindsets of success
they have to just jump in the in the on
the journey
and don't think about money or or
traveling just
go for it you know yeah it's very
difficult to
to make people doing stuff you know but
by by saying by uh by my example for
example
then then they can be maybe be expired
or something so
it's not not easy it was not easy for me
because you know sweden is there
england's here traveling booking a hotel
you know
finding the right place to live and
stuff like is is difficult but not
impossible
how many times since you secured the
hotel
yeah on your big day straight after the
deal finding extravaganza how many times
have you
been back to england this is his first
time actually i haven't even been to
england because it's the covey that's
why
i couldn't come but you've been making
all this money yes from sweden
so you can kind of do it from overseas
absolutely once you've put together the
team
absolutely so you came down did the
training
got the deals yes bagged it up went back
to sweden
and then it was kind of systemized yeah
zoom meetings telephone calls
whatsapp chatting yeah just literal
business business you know
it's like you put the time and effort in
the beginning yeah spent a few weeks
yeah boom pushing it yeah that was like
your financial freedom challenge
one more time that was like your
financial thing exactly you beat me
really yeah because i didn't get a hotel
right but most people i think most
people live their life with their foot
on the accelerator but also their foot
on the brake
yeah yeah yeah and they're like
wondering why they're not getting very
far
even on the crash course i'm like at the
property investors crash course which is
a free program yes i'll say
call an agent go on go on right move do
this just yeah and a lot of people don't
they're like oh let me just take notes
and i'll do it when i get home and i'm
trying to make i'm like
do it now yes but it's deal finding
extravaganza's
not quite like that because they've paid
to be there yeah yeah so they're a bit
more
you know but i think um you know you
have to take your foot off of the break
exactly and just and just go full gas
you know yeah like you drive porsche
what would your biggest advice to
somebody then in how to get into
property oh my god that's that's uh
my advice my advice i can say like this
uh
you have to go for it you know you don't
have to uh you don't have to go to 100
millions of courses
and learn learn and learn you just have
to jump
jump in the in the business somehow jump
jump and just start
start to teach to learn to learn stuff
by doing stuff yeah yeah i know many
people who
who attend many many courses they just
get
better and better and better in like
information like
knowledge better nobody
go for it yeah i'm not nobody but not so
many people that's the
the wrong the wrong mindset for many
people
they don't do it they just teach teach
teach learn learn
learn learn but that's that's not my
students though yeah i know
but you can't you have to do it when
you're when you're on my training
programs you can't
just learn learn learn you know because
part of the part of the
the curriculum yeah is to go and do you
must go out you must go out
just so you think taking action is the
biggest thing exactly taking action
bigger than anything so much absolutely
without thinking just jump
yeah like i said like like i have one
like this i have one
impression like this if you cannot swim
you know what to do
you jump in the water with no skills
and you t you learn how to swim in the
water
yeah directly but it's like driving it's
like if you're trying to learn to drive
by reading a theory book yes you can
read the theory book
over and over you can put it back to
front but then when you get in the car
that's when you learn to drive
absolutely now by all means have an
instructor in the car with you
right for sure but you have to do it yes
so i think that's really really
interesting
um what have been the biggest lessons
throughout the past year or so from what
you've done
oh my god less i got so many lessons you
know
one of them is trust people you know
because without trusting people
you cannot succeed yeah it's impossible
because many people think
that 99 from this we talk now it's come
it's not possible you know many people
but you must trust
sometimes when you trust you lose but
that's that's the game
losing win you know you cannot only only
win
so i think that trust you trust people
and you
i think everybody must be kind of uh
his own psychological psychologist you
know to
to to to be able to talk with people
to i mean talk people and and
and and find out what the people
how people are thinking how the people
are like experienced you know
so can i trust them can i not trust them
you know it's like a little bit like
this
you cannot just go you have to do some
maybe some
talking you know my phone so try
i mean trust people did you see my
social experiment where i tried to give
away a free house
yes i saw it two girls were talking to
two girls i saw yeah
yeah i i don't know if you were even at
the course
maybe you were because i did it in
around about the same sort of time but
that was a
that was a a replication of something i
did in real life a training program i
tried to give away i don't know if you
were there
i tried it was a crash course i tried to
give away a house to a guy at a crash
course i haven't been there now okay you
wearing that one
okay to be fair i was doing a crash
course a week before the pandemic
but there was a guy called phil and phil
was very skeptical
and i tried to give phil a free house
really and phil said he needed to think
about it i said how long do you did
three hours three weeks three months he
said give me a few hours
i went no problem here's the contract go
speak to your solicitor
read it and then in three hours i'll
give you a free house
right for real yes three hours later i
said are you ready he said i'm ready to
go ahead i'm really happy thank you so
much i said congratulations here's the
pen let's get it signed he said oh hold
on
i've he said i've got a rule i'll have i
have to have a face-to-face meeting with
my wife before i sign anything
okay i said okay no problem i've got a
rule as well i don't i don't work with
people like you i signed it myself
he then went on to troll me online as if
i'd robbed him of a house
we filmed the whole thing crazy i didn't
put it out publicly
because i didn't want to humiliate him i
didn't want to get into any trouble
exactly
but i then duplicated the exercise in
hyde park in london
yeah and i did the same thing because
people didn't believe the story no
people like no
surely not i went in in london and i
think you're right sometimes people
think if it sounds too good to be true
it probably is
which means anything that good comes
along it's a scam
it's a scam or they'll sabotage it yeah
even a good woman that's the catch
and if you look hard enough for a catch
you'll find one exactly even if you've
imagined it and i think what you're
saying is so true about
you have to trust people of course you
do need to do your due diligence
exactly you need to trust your gut
exactly and but but sometimes we can be
so
untrusting of people that we never take
any risk at all
but the bottom line is entrepreneurship
you have to take some risks
even if they're educated risks and i
think i agree with you taking action
yes now i believe take action like you
did get the
education yes but don't spend so long
months and months and months learning
learning learning no goodness get the
right mentor
get some training but then just grab the
ball by the horns and go and that's what
you've done yeah and that's why you've
succeeded
yes what's it been like working with me
one more time what's it been like
working with me
if i would like to work with you no
what's it been like
working with me you mean
like oh you mean like from your training
courses we've been speaking a lot
on it's been perfect you know because
when i speak with you
i'm always like feeling the energy
always you know that's what i need
energy you know yeah so
i i mean you're a perfect speaker you
know
i've been trying to i've been tr we've
been trying to do this
yeah for months we've been speaking
yeah exactly and and and we could have
done it on zoom
but we decided let's meet and do it in
person probably this is the best meeting
you know
face to face zoom is like not real for
me yeah
yeah yeah this is the base face to face
one to one it's the best meeting ever so
it's it's such a pleasure that's why i
just came here
you know it's such a pleasure working
with you i'm so proud of what you've
done thank you
i know you've got some massive new
things coming in the future absolutely
um
what would you say if someone wants to
get in touch with you what's the best
way to get in touch facebook instagram
facebook is the best you know so it's
george
my name great stuff but i can give you a
little bit later maybe
i can give you some details maybe yeah
but facebook is the best you know my
name is george drumeff
yeah just uh gold facebook george
drummond sky my face my smiley face
what does your wife think about what
you've done oh she's so proud of me you
know yeah she was in the beginning with
me
but now she she went uh to her own path
she she became a
life coach okay and this is her journey
you know because properties became like
a
mind journey yeah and she's uh her
journey was teaching people
like life coaching and stuff like that
why did you choose property
why i think that question
because property you know like he says
this is very this is beautiful
the property is something which is there
i mean a house
yeah and this this house you can go
there you can see it you can touch it
you can smell it yeah it's like a real
real asset that's why i love real assets
you know
yeah that's why i choose property
because it's something you you own
and something when you build your
portfolio property portfolio
you can leave this portfolio to your
kids and you know to just
to secure their life forever yeah their
kids and their kids and
well i think you deserve every success
you've got because not only if you take
a massive action
but you've also got a beautiful heart
you know and you're a real good guy and
you
you were really supportive of me as well
you know and you have been you've been
you've been a real good student a real
good advocate thank you a real good
businessman so i really appreciate
you've been an
asset to the training that we've done
because you've brought such massive
energy
yeah so i just want to as well say thank
you um thank you for the
for for the energy and the success that
you bring and uh i look forward to
seeing you
um continue to blossom over the coming
months and years so massive
i promise i promise great stuff guys
i hope you enjoyed that i think you'll
agree george is an incredibly
inspirational
entrepreneur please do me a massive
favor hit the like button to show some
support and some love for george
also if you want to see more interviews
like that every single week in fact i
even wrote a whole book
okay on on these um on these stories
because people
i've just got so many people succeeding
i could i've got people
booked up for weeks and weeks and weeks
i could literally do a success
story every day if i had the physical
time so if you want to see over a
hundred of these interviews
then you can check out a whole playlist
up here and be inspired by many many
many more people
that have walked the path of financial
freedom
also don't forget to subscribe you can
subscribe up here
i hope to see you at some live physical
free training which you can get
in the description on the link below
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
you